[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous pensez transports en
commun parisiens écoutez pour les
emprunter manière occasionnelle je
trouve que selon les lignes on peut
effectivement avoir des différences
marquées
tout passe très bien quelques toiles le
créneau horaire si vous prenez la 13 que
je prends occasionnellement à des choses
peuvent vite compliqué vous les premiers
en famille alors en famille oui alors là
effectivement j'ai la chance moi d'avoir
plus de trois enfants donc je bénéficie
d'un tarif qui me permet effectivement
des prendre relativement régulièrement
sans s'agrègent mon budget vous vous
retrouvez effectivement à faire des
rachats de deux tickets assez rapide ça
va c'est quoi que pour les transports
ouais c'est mon frérot pourrait dire ça
mauvaise pioche
paul était en bonne fin de journée mon
futur mais c'est clair et finalement ça
perdure pas mal la visite transporter et
votre très long pour toi une part parce
qu'on m'a déjà fait le coup vous pensez
quoi des transports en commun page
je trouve qu'ils sont bien pratiques
il ya parfois des problèmes mais
généralement c'est bien c'est utile il
ya du monde mais faut s'y faire
vous les prenez souvent très souvent way
tous les jours et on est votre sera elle
en pense quoi
mon frère est en pense attention soit
9,0 qui était venu en métro j'avais en
rollers moi je suis un raider deus from
side il part d'un an que son rôle de
parent non non et c'est la catastrophe
prudent ice one
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et devant parlera de l'avenir de camions
bull donne rendez vous et merci mon
chéri d'amour version